à suivre une telle cour à un cannelloni
la poudre d'hibiscus ça va donner de
l'acidité on va rester sur le bas les
années tu prouves fait partie de ma
brigade vous vous pliez à mes règles ils
ont aimé ou pas c'est pas ma question à
6 c'est la question qu'on doit se poser
quand on est choqué s'cusez moi c'est
bon ben moi je me casse et du boulanger
pas cela na waïe titre s'ils m'avaient
donné ta carte oui ça lui ces 4 6 marie
l appareil basique qui me rappelle alors
je cherche lorenzo cardy c'est pour le
poste de chef de cuisine le restaurant
du coup le lieu charme comme c'est ici
ce temps foyer c'est à dire ce sont des
jeunes mineurs en attente de papiers les
migrants on a un peut extrapoler
le vigneau faillite a le moindre
problème plutôt qu'à ma porte bonne nuit
à larry tu m'entends que je crains comme
ça ah non à peine
et qu'elle en fait vous avez vu l'état
la cuisine je peux pas tenir les
horaires pour 70 personnes celles ci
vous avez besoin d'être beau demander au
joli 6 attendre que ça
enfin c'est pas possible ils sont
combien cet avis ils sont très motivés
vous avez des planches et des icônes
sommes là ce chrono ne savent rien faire
bah oui
c'est cucul c'est la tête c'est ça qu'on
veut d'accord c'est quoi ça ça c'est
stylé mais non c'est pas style et ses
crabes
je me fastidieux pour devenir chef
christine goll également compliquée
devant moi ton tata qu'il vole à le
croiser des semaines entre la terre et
la mer éclate sur le palais arrondi la
mise en bouche j'ai rien compris
ce magnifique ça non
[Musique]
comment ça se passe un plouc fois
studieux chef
ça
va être lourde je sens qu'avec londres